hey what's up guys my name is echano
welcome back to my game engine
series so last time we extended our
scriptable entity component we just
talked about a better way potentially to
do
scriptable entities i know that's still
a hot topic it's a hot debate check out
that video
if you haven't already we're going to
move away a little bit from all the
scriptable entity stuff because for now
we have native script component we have
a way to actually script
our entities natively and at the moment
obviously we're working towards kind of
like a minimum viable product just to
get everything
up and running so that you can actually
start creating scenes and making games
within hazel so that part i'm marking is
pretty much done for now because it does
what it needs to do
and we're going to move on to uh
actually
doing some fun stuff today hopefully
where we're going to take a look
at and i need to hide chat we're going
to take a look at
the uh scene hierarchy panel today
essentially so what the scene hierarchy
panel is
and this is kind of the next step in
what we're doing i think i will make
next potentially next game engine series
video i want to make a little bit of
like a road map planning
video just to basically publish some
sort of online road map that
that you know will contain information
about what it is we're working towards
just so that it's a little bit more
clear
both both for me but also for everyone
watching because
i think it's really important to make
sure that your plan is uh
solid and that you're going to stick to
that plan otherwise again making a game
engine very difficult
very arbitrary and it's uh you know it's
going to wind up
being super annoying when uh you forget
what you're supposed to be working on
so definitely going to do something like
that next time but essentially what what
we've kind of decided to do here
and i think it's a reasonable decision
is we want to
construct this we want to basically make
it so that you can make something in
hazel right
the 2d workflow is something that we've
been prioritizing for a while so i've
arbitrarily picked a game and we're
going to
work towards implementing all the
features to make that happen so in other
words you know we we've
well i think last time with this whole
situation
uh and let me just make sure that this
was yeah this does look correct
um so we can move the camera
obviously and uh you know we have the
ability to add some native scripts now
the next step really is i want to be
able to construct some sort of scene
using hazelnut hazelnut is supposed to
be kind of like a level editor
so in order in order to actually you
know for it to actually function as a
level editor
i want to be able to you know make
entities
maybe add like a sprite component to
them maybe set that to a solid color or
to a texture
position it in my world and just you
know navigate my world maybe using some
kind of editor camera
i want to be able to do all that stuff
so that i can essentially construct a
scene
once we have a scene constructed and you
can actually manipulate entities and add
new entities add components to those
entities maybe add native script
components
to those entities as well then we now
have a way to actually
make a scene and then we'll work towards
maybe making like a play button or
something that we can click
that will actually transition into our
scenes runtime
so that we can actually play our game
and then you know we'll talk about that
whole process as well because it's going
to be quite involved
and then we can also you know do other
stuff revolving the editor and scenes
and stuff like that such as
civilization so we want to be able to
obviously save our work instead of just
hitting close and then everything
disappears that's
not what we want um and also potentially
even
uh running the game standalone outside
of the editor
so that that kind of bubble of work is
what we're going to be working towards
and we're going to be approaching it
from like a you know minimum viable
product mvp kind of vertical slice
situation which is basically fancy talk
for like
you know let's just do all of the low
hanging fruit let's just do everything
the easy kind of fast way but also not
you know to
not in a still reasonable way right just
to get it
up and running the minimum what's the
minimum viable
like solution we have here for this to
be usable let's start there
and then we'll start refining it and
iterating over it so that's what we're
going to be doing here
so today i thought that it would be a
good idea to start by creating a new
panel
and this is going to be our scene
hierarchy panel this is going to be
essentially containing the hierarchy of
our scene we're going to be able to see
all of the entities in our scene here
we're kind of
you know manually uh actually displaying
them in the ui here so we have green
square you know
camera a you know we're kind of
displaying some of them and some of
their properties here
but what i want to be doing obviously is
having like an actual hierarchy
where we can list out all of the
entities that are currently in our scene
so we need to actually
iterate through our whole entity
component system and retrieve all the
entities
once we've done that we can make them
like you know selectable and all that
stuff so that you can maybe see
their properties and their components in
another kind of
uh properties or inspector panel
something like that and then we can also
make it so that we can add entities
remove
entities add components remove
components all that stuff so lots of ui
work that has to be done
in order for us to actually be able to
make a scene
inside hazelnut so let's start by going
over to
uh hazelnut so hazelnut is the level
editor right so this stuff
is is you know all the level editor kind
of stuff and let me just show all files
here
all of the level editor stuff has to be
in here so i'm going to call this editor
even though the whole thing is an editor
and then inside here actually you know
what let's call this panels
panels so i've made a folder called
panels and inside there i'm going to
make a panel here
called scene hierarchy panel scene
hierarchy
panel dot h
and also dot cpp
all right we'll include the pch
actually do we are we compiling all this
with a pc we're not compiling this for
the pch okay we'll get all that for now
we should probably write a pch for
hazelnut as well
um we'll still have this as hazel's
namespace
um and then we'll call this uh the scene
hierarchy panel of course
uh include scene hierarchy panel okay so
the
premise here as i mentioned is quite
simple and let me zoom in maybe
because i know people want that uh
namespace hazel
the premise for this is quite simple uh
and we are going to be
referring to hazeldev where i've already
i have had to see in hiking panel for
probably
around a year so that's that's nice
um i'm gooey is what i wanted to include
so where is i'm gui
i think we can just include it like that
all right so the way that i like to set
up the scene hierarchy panel essentially
is i like to uh have it actually take a
ref of a scene
now whether or not it should actually
take the ref so in other words keep it
alive or not that's potentially
debatable
but overall when you create a scene
hierarchy panel you should make it take
in a ref
and additionally you should probably
have a
set context function that actually sets
the context so in other words the
context of course is the scene
because that's the context of the same
hierarchy panel it's displaying the
hierarchy of a particular
scene so we need to actually have this
here and again i am going to have this
as like uh
we'll call it context i will have this
as a rep as a strong ref meaning that
you know if the scene gets deleted then
potentially the scene hierarchy panel
could still retain it
we'll include uh hazel scene
scene we should also include ref
of course and uh or will it i mean it
should have oh no
i forgot that well intrusive we're
counting just yet
so we'll also need to include like four
days i think
okay so we've got all that now uh we we
have set context and then we also want
to add probably a lot of functions here
such as set selected so that way we can
actually programmatically select an
entity that's useful for
you know for example if we clicked
somewhere in the scene to actually mouse
pick
an entity we would want the panel to
reflect the fact that it's selected now
and all that stuff we're not gonna
bother with that again you know doing
some simple stuff here the real
big thing that we do need though is
something called onion gui render
obviously because
that is what's actually going to render
our panel so let's go ahead and
implement this stuff
um yeah let's
okay yeah okay let's implement all these
i'll implement set context is for now
probably just going to be a setup but
in the future i may actually and let's
call this context
i may actually have it do more because
it's possible that we need to update
something and you know
so that's why i implemented it in the
cpp file and yeah we'll also call set
context
here with the context okay
so i'm gui render we'll do i'm going
begin this is going to be our scene
hierarchy
i'm going end
and then we can start drawing a
basically like this whole tree
now uh as i mentioned i have done this
in halo dev
so it's going to be a lot easier to just
you know
use that so the way that i actually set
this up here
was i used ant of course to iterate
through everything so what we'll do is
we'll make
we'll say friend class scene so that we
can actually
uh let scene access all of our private
stuff except actually i just realized
that
this is going to be a little bit
different we're actually going to go to
scene and we're going to do friend class
scene hierarchy panel
so that's going to allow us to access
all this stuff i don't think c needs to
access this
um and so what this should let us do is
hopefully inside context
um we can now access the registry
and we can actually iterate through
everything inside our registry by just
using each so this lets
us submit a lambda here um and we're
going to
i think it takes in a we'll just do
order entity which is going to be that
entity identifier and then this is going
to
uh iterate through every single entity
in our registry
so just to make sure that this works you
know we can just kind of
just use i'm gui text here and actually
maybe get
like the tag component from the entity
and print that so let's try that so
let's just do
m context and registry and then we'll do
get
um uh yeah sure we'll do get
and then gets what i'm thinking of right
and then maybe tag component and then
entity so that should give us our
tag or the tag component tc
and then we can just do let's just do s
and then we'll do tc.tag
all right so if we basically create a
scene hierarchy panel
and then uh iterate and then call on i'm
going render we should be able to
from our editor layer we should be able
to actually
see all of our entities already um so
let's just do
include scene hierarchy panel
um i don't know we'll do like panels
down here maybe
we'll make a ref from it saying
hierarchy panel
um i mean we don't have to make a ref
from it um
but i will just so that we can control
it
no i'm not going to let's just routine
hierarchy panel panel like that
i'm not going to make a ref out of it uh
scene hierarchy panel and then we're
going to make another constructor here
that actually
just doesn't do anything so that we
don't have to actually
have a constructor that sets the context
so that way that will be fine and then
inside editor layer
we can actually maybe inside on attach
you know maybe at the bottom even i'll
just say
m scene hierarchy
and panel m scene hierarchy panel
um dot set context to active scene
okay so now we have a context and now we
just need to render everything so inside
on i'm going render
inside our dock panel of course uh we've
got settings over here which is kind of
the big one
we're going to eventually get rid of
that so over here i will do
on i'm guiranza so this is us actually
rendering
our scene hierarchy panel let's hit f5
and see what we get so we should see a
list of entities hopefully
or a build error you know that's also
cool i just spilled
quite a bit of water
never mind references must be
initialized all right i clearly didn't
do this right
um can we not just use uh
get with this i mean i guess we could
you know you know what let's make this
into an actual hazel entity
i'll call this ftid so uh entity
don't need to really use equals and then
the scene being
context raw the reason i want to do this
is because we're obviously going to be
doing a lot of stuff with the entity not
just
this and so we might as well use our own
api for it just because it cleans things
up a bit
so this now just becomes entity yes
component
like that and yeah let's let's check
this out
still doesn't work all right context is
an undeclared identifier
uh all right we need to capture that
let's just capture it by
well we'll capture it by reference we
could capture it by value doesn't really
matter
uh entity uses undefined clock okay we
need to include some stuff
let's include it up here because we will
actually need
it up here um because eventually we're
going to keep track of the currently
selected entities
that we can probably display our
inspector and so i might as well include
it in the header file now
all right lots of problems what's going
on so context
dot raw is not a thing
really ah
roy is not a member of shared pointers
in oh sorry it's not raw let's get
i'm just used to my own intrusive like
reference counting
refs and stuff uh tag component i think
is an include that we should have
include hazel uh scene
scene components
hst core error identify not found
uh where is this stuff stored in core
base
and what we're trying to compile here
entity.h
uh that's a bit odd isn't it
because i definitely included bass here
and
uh maybe we need enable asserts turned
on
um yeah we probably need to actually
make sure that hz debug is enabled here
otherwise i guess we won't
get assets so let's uh
this is something that we actually need
to do inside pre-make
for hazelnut which is now moved here i
believe so
this is hazelnut right no actually we do
define debug
ah that's odd i thought maybe we didn't
so then why is
this stuff not actually that doesn't
make any sense
anyway because if it if it wasn't um
it just wouldn't compile to anything but
it just can't find a hz core error so
where is h0 core error defined
h said core error
uh it's inside oh it's inside log okay
that makes sense
so let's go back to maybe
here and let's include log
i probably should have just included
hazel.h but i want it to be clever
all right that's better uh let's hit f5
and hopefully we should now
run oh almost very close
couldn't find that because that of
course we put into panels
and here we go i think this is it i
think we're finally ready to see this
all right awesome there it is isn't it
beautiful oh it's a disaster yeah i
forgot to convert it into a char pointer
so let's go back out here and uh tag dot
c
string that's what we want because i'm
gui wants an actual pointer to some data
pointed to some characters not
necessarily a string an
scd string all right check this out so
we now have our scene hierarchy panel
let's put it up here
settings you know let's just put this
over here for now
um and i i will commit this i'm going to
ini file so if you pull you should
kind of get the same layout so over here
we have clip space entity camera entity
and green square
right we can now list all of the
entities in our scene how cool
is that let's close this and then let's
extend this a little bit to make it um
better so what i want to do next is
basically say that well the first thing
that we should probably do
is somehow validate whether or not this
entity is
valid because we don't necessarily want
to display maybe all entities in our
scene
um we don't really have a good way of
doing this yet potentially we could look
at whether or not the entity has a
certain component such as like an id
component in the future
or maybe even a tag component if it
doesn't have a tag component that's a
bit suspicious maybe it's some kind of
hazel internal entity because as you
know
whenever we create an entity we uh
always give it a tag component right i
mean we always give it a transform
component
debatable whether or not we need that
probably not but we always give it a tag
component that's just how it works
um but i'm not going to bother with that
so instead what we're going to do
is do draw entity node
entity right so at this point what i'm
doing is i'm going to make a new
function here
it's going to be private and i'm going
to make a special section for private
functions
we'll call this void draw entity node
and
then this is going to take in a hazel
entity
just by value like that okay so this
draw entity node
uh function uh is going to first of all
well it's gonna at least do this right
but now we're going to actually see
hopefully the entity node and the entity
knows specifically
is going to hopefully well it's going to
do a number of things the biggest thing
that we wanted to actually do
is have a selectable list of entities
and that's what we're going to
work on today um so the way that we the
way that i did this inside hazeldev was
i used something called well the imgui
tree nodes
one thing i want to recommend here
because i'm not going to like
re-implement this whole thing i'm
probably just going to copy and paste
some of the code that i've got here and
then explain it and walk you guys
through it
uh because it probably took me like an
hour to work out um but the way that i
like to deal with imgui
is you'll see that included with hazel
is this imguidemo.cpp file which is
provided by i am gooey i specifically
didn't delete this file
because it's very useful we have about
5000 lines almost
of i am gui demo code so this is code on
how you can use imgui
anywhere in your whole project well
specifically in like the imgui section
you can literally just drop one of these
i'm going to show
demo windows like that done right
if you write this code it's going to
display the demo window
you can now see the demo window right
here it is
the imgui demo and you can browse it and
you can find
something that you want like for example
oh look at this
look at these like kind of header things
and it looks like some kind of parented
list that looks almost like a scene
hierarchy well guess what you can
actually
find this code inside that imguidemo.cpp
file
and see how they did it because
obviously this is built using imgui
and it you know it goes to show for like
this for example you know oh cool you
can make an image pop up that just
display stuff
you know you can find that code inside
that demo thing combo boxes
you know that's obviously something
that's useful text input multi-line text
input maybe you want to make like a
little code editor
be a bit annoying doing it this way but
i guess it's possible
different data types you know color
pickers you know oh i want to have a
color picker
that looks like this right here you can
find all of that stuff right
this is the number one thing that i
consult whenever i have to do something
with i'm going
for sure it is this i'm gui demo window
because it's so
so so useful okay so that's basically
the short story of how i worked out how
to do all of this stuff
but luckily for you i've already worked
out how to do all this stuff so i don't
have to waste
too much time instead we're going to try
well actually i might type this out
because there's a lot of stuff going on
in hazel dev that we don't necessarily
want
so for each entity node we want to get
the tag component and we want to see
what it is now
there are it is possible to have a tag
component that is empty
as you know and in fact maybe it's not
because i think what we ended up doing
is
we just called it entity so we can have
an nc called entity
right i think i may have called it
unnamed and seen hazel there but
ultimately
we have a name here right it's tc and in
fact we can just take
tc.tag and that way uh that way we just
have tag
right ready to go this is going to be a
string now i've
i'm taking it as not a const reference
because we're also going to eventually
make it possible
to edit the name but that'll probably be
done using the inspector panel or the
properties panel
instead of the actual uh scene hierarchy
panel of course
all right so once we have the tag what
i'm going to do
is basically call something called i am
gui tree node ex
and i'm going tree node ex is going to
uh
this is what is that tree node that you
saw there right we probably we actually
need to supply
supply some flags to it as well but the
one the overload that we'll use is one
that takes in a pointer id because what
i'm actually going to do
is i'm going needs a unique id to
actually identify this tree node right
that's how i'm going works it needs like
unique identifiers for pretty much every
component so that it can then respond to
input and do certain things with them
so what we're going to actually do is
take the entity
right uh this actually
this is a little bit dodgy because this
un-32t
pointer or rather sorry this un-32t is a
32-bit
uh ncid but this void pointer is likely
it's going to be 64 bits on a 64-bit
platform
so i'm actually having second thoughts
about this but what we could do is just
get
the actual ant id actually i think we
can do we add a
cast for that no we didn't i thought we
may have
uh
i don't really want to take the memory
address of this either i was just going
to use the
end yeah let's do this okay so what
we'll do is we'll
write operator uint32t
because that's what the entity id is
uh id type i think id type is
always going to be a 32-bit one
i don't think they do 64-bit at all so
what we'll do is we'll add an operator
for this
that just returns the entity handle
as a un-32t like this
so this is just like instead of us
actually having to write
you know a function called get id
we can just add a cast operator like
that so that now we can just
cast our entity to a unit 32t but then
i'm going to cast that
to a 60 40 i don't know if that's
necessary
actually but it sounds like it i mean it
probably isn't right because if i'm
casting this to avoid pointer
um and this is not like a pointer to
pointer cast
maybe this isn't necessary but
ultimately
i don't even know ultimately what this
is doing is it's
i'm going tree note ex takes a takes a
pointer right it just takes a void
pointer i think
why not yeah it takes takes a void
pointer
now it's a void pointer but essentially
a point is just an integer
and what what we're going what we need
to provide it with is a unique
identifier for this tree node
for this actual tree node right and so
what we're doing is we're
using the entities id to serve as the
identifier for this tree node
like ui component and
uh obviously that is a good thing to do
like obviously that's
that will work because entities are all
unique you'll never have the same entity
twice in this scene hierarchy panel
so that's all great but the problem is
that
i'm not really sure how this stuff works
because
um you know obviously this ncid is a
32-bit value whereas maybe if we cast
into a 64-bit value it could mess some
stuff up
but to be honest i'm not 100 sure
if yeah chat seems to be saying that it
is necessary so we'll leave it here
we'll still classes to a 64 t um which
we'll just basically convert that into a
64-bit uh integer
and then that we're basically saying is
like you know whatever use it as a void
pointer
because obviously we're never going to
be using the address of this void
pointer it's just using it as a value
i mean this function could have taken in
an int or a 64-bit end but it takes an
avoid pointer
all right sorry long explanation
probably but i just wanted that to be
clear
i'm going to take in something called
flags and then i guess i'll use tag.c
string
as um
[Music]
as the name right so this is this cons
char
format thing here is um the actual name
of the node right so that's the actual
label that will show up and it gives it
to you as like a format with variable
arguments so you can basically use it
like printf
or any of the other functions if you
want to like display a number and format
your string essentially
all right flags so we need i am gooey
tree node flags now this has a bunch of
different flags
and the ones that we're going to use is
basically
as i mentioned we want to be able to uh
both expand these
because in the future
we're going to so what is it it's open
on arrow so we want to be able to
actually
expand them because we'll have parented
entities and we want to be able to
expand and collapse those groups
open on arrow is a flag that just means
that you can
you have to click on the actual arrow
that will show up if you want to expand
it instead of on the whole row
because we want to obviously be able to
click on the row
to select an entity and that's what
we'll also do here so basically
um we have the option to also add
another flag and these these are just
bit flag so you can order them together
called i am gui tree node flags uh
selected i think if you add this flag
it will show up as selected right so
if we add that here they'll all look
like they're selected so what we
actually want to do is keep track of the
currently selected entity
well that's pretty easy because every
entity has a unique id
so what we can actually do is say entity
m
selection context and all you can select
identity so it's not that difficult
so this should just have a null entity
to begin with and we can say that if m
a selection context equals entity i
don't know if we can compare them like
this but we definitely need to be able
to
then we can uh include this otherwise
just
zero right and then we'll all that
together
with the open arrow because we want that
for every single thing
okay but this is just for selected stuff
all right um
we don't have a way to compare entities
which is great
uh so let's add that in here
let's do uh operator
rather this will be a bull operator
uh equals equals const
so what we need to do here return entity
handle equals
const entity other anti-handle equals
other dot
anti-handle and amscene equals other dot
i'm saying so the pointers have to be
the same and the ids have to be the same
and that's our operator equals equals
and then operator does not equal
we'll basically just return i would call
this a number of ways we just do return
operator equals equals other and then
return
that okay or you can
you can also do return this
uh equals other i don't think you need
the parentheses
i don't know i guess maybe this one
looks cleaner
you are referencing this and that might
look weird but this is clearly you okay
i'll just return this sorry
um it'll be you you do need this it's
the it'll be the opposite of that
so that all right we'll leave it we'll
leave it as that i don't know what's
better to be honest
um so uh in terms of what looks better
so now this should work obviously there
you go
and now we can tell what the selected
entity is i mean we can't select them
yet but obviously in this case nothing
will be
uh selected because we're not we don't
have a selection context
so here's the thing though we've now
we're now drawing our node so the next
thing we want to do is actually
respond to it being clicked so we can do
if i am going
is item clicked right so if the previous
item which is the
tree node gets clicked then we want to
set the selection context equal to
entity
and then in hazel tab i also have like a
selection changed callback but we're not
gonna deal with that right now
okay um then we have some pop-up menus
which we'll ignore
and then uh this stuff is also stupid
and then
i think that's pretty much it um all
right so this actually
uh this actually returns whether or not
the tree node has been expanded
and obviously if it has been expanded we
want to uh you know
basically uh continue recursively going
down that
tree and expand everything well not
necessarily expand everything but
you know if the if this entity has any
child density we want to display that we
don't have any concept of charges just
yet
so this is easy all we need to do is say
that if it has been opened let's just
call traypop
and that's it okay that's it
that's it um now we should have
essentially selectable
entities that's pretty cool let's hit f5
that's actually not that bad
it looks a lot more scary in hazel dev
but it's really not that bad
when you cut out all of the other extra
stuff
i mean we don't know if it works yet but
okay so we have these clips face
entities look at this i can select them
right so you can see that if i click on
them they stay selected
right and i can expand them now
expanding them currently does nothing
but like you know you could easily do
another one of these here
i'll just do this as a demo so let's do
um let's do the same thing
as a test except this time i'll
do entity plus a thousand
please ignore what i'm doing i'm just
ruining everything
but i have to
otherwise it's gonna be the same idea
and it's gonna mess stuff up
uh what did i do wrong here
what did i even want to do uh
what that looks right to me
oh no i've got well
oh this was a mistake okay uh change of
plans
we're going to give this one a stupid id
all right that's going to be the same
[ __ ]
anyway it doesn't matter is it just a
test um stop it so flags
and then it doesn't even matter we'll
just remove the selected flag because
we're not going to be able to select it
all right so this
is just an example to prove that the
expanding stuff works so
if we take a look at this then uh you
can see that if i press the arrow we
have this clip space empty here right
it's not gonna go any further but
we can expand all of these they look
nice and we are gonna clean up the
styling of this like we're not gonna use
this font and we're going to probably
make stuff a bit bigger
maybe and like just the way that this
looks it looks a lot prettier obviously
and hazel to have different colors as
well
but the main kind of uh you know
component is here right
and we now have a way to select this so
the cool thing is that we can now
reflect this selection
and display all of the components of the
currently selected entity in another
panel
and i think that is what we'll do next
time so
hope you guys enjoyed this video
uh let me find my right overlay uh if
you have any questions don't forget to
leave them in the comment
section below next time as i mentioned
we're going to take a look at creating
that inspector panel i don't know let me
know what you guys want do you want the
uh do you want the properties panel do
you want the inspector panel next time
okay my point is it's the same panel
sorry i got started by chat
um it's the same panel we need to call
it either the inspector panel
or the properties panel i called it i
think i called it properties inside
hazel dev if you have any other
suggestions
and i was frequently called something
like inspector in unity
if you have a name suggestion definitely
leave that in the comments section below
and uh yeah i will see you guys next
time don't forget to hit the like button
and
patreon.com if you want to help support
this series everything i'm doing here
on youtube and otherwise you'll get
access to hazeldev which is where a lot
of this code already
is implemented and a lot of that code
came from and
uh what else and you know there's some
other things like live stream recordings
and
uh you know much much more actually no
that's about it
thank you guys for watching i'll see you
next time goodbye
[Music]
you